6 44 new overnight progress in Carson
City late Wednesday Governor Joe
Lombardo signed two major bills and a
bipartisan deal with legislative
Democrats top on the list Senate Bill
503 the education budget providing
nearly 12 billion dollars to Public
Schools over two years that's a two
billion dollar increase overall in
school funding Governor Lombardo also
signed SB 504 that puts nearly 11
billion dollars into Nevada's Medicaid
Program both measures come after very
hard negotiations with Democrats but
they do pave the way for other
legislation to move forward including a
bill to audit school districts which
passed unanimously out of the State
Assembly yesterday still has to get
through the state senate though so
audits will be done by the legislature's
research division moving forward for all
schools in this in the state Governor
Lombardo demanded audits of public
schools at the beginning of the session
Heather